vous le savez sans doute depuis le début
du 21e siècle nous faisons face à un
très grand nombre de défis
environnementaux et si les deux plus
graves sont probablement la disparition
de la biodiversité et le changement
climatique
on pourra aussi parler de l'autre au
fise ation des déchets plastiques du pic
pétrolier de l'épuisement des ressources
pas été importante pour l'agriculture
des pénuries probable sur certaines
ressources métallique de la pollution de
l'eau et de sa sueur utilisation de
diverses pollutions chimiques et ainsi
de suite
de l'avis de beaucoup d'experts ces
problèmes peuvent provoquer de nombreux
effets néfastes pour nos sociétés
à moins d'un changement radical dans nos
façons de produire et de consommer
certains envisagent même la possibilité
d'un effondrement de nos sociétés
industrielles notamment à cause de notre
très forte dépendance aux ressources
fossiles et ce possiblement dans un
futur pas si éloigné comme 2040
même si vous êtes sceptique vis-à-vis de
ces catastrophes environnementales
il semble très irrationnel de les
exclure entièrement le futur semble très
incertain
il semble très présomptueux d'en
délimiter les contours en particulier si
vous n'a signé qu'une probabilité d'un
sur 1000 aux désastres environnementaux
et à leurs conséquences majeures sur les
civilisations humaines
sachant l'ampleur des conséquences
néfastes il sera alors très irrationnel
de ne pas donner beaucoup d'importance à
ce cas peu probable
comme l'expliquent monsieur py dans
cette vidéo avec un autre exemple est
une toute autre source d'incertitudes
épistémique en fait pour aujourd'hui
je vous demande de jouer pleinement le
jeu faisons l'expérience de pensée
imaginons qu'à moins d'un changement
radical dans nos comportements nous nous
exposons à de graves impacts globaux
d'ici disons 2040 avec potentiellement
des millions voire des milliards de
morts dans d'horribles souffrances
en supposant pour aujourd'hui que ce
risque est majeur que devrions nous
faire
et attention par nous je n'entends pas
le gouvernement où toute la société
parce que c'est tellement facile de
rejeter la faute sur autre chose que
nous et parce qu à l inverse c'est aussi
extrêmement difficile de faire faire
quoi que ce soit un gouvernement ou à
toute une société
non la question que je pose c'est de
savoir ce que nous notre communauté de
gens qui regardent once and for all et
le youtube éducatif et qui sommes sans
doute plus motivés que le citoyen médian
pour entreprendre des actions en faveur
de l'environnement
qu'est ce que nous devrions faire qu'est
ce que moi je devrais faire
et qu'est-ce que toi qui regarde cette
vidéo qu'est-ce que tu devrais faire
alors bien sûr tu pourras quand c'est
par trier les déchets manger moins de
viande
utilisez les transports polluants
améliorer l'isolation thermique total
maison est acheté moins de produits qui
ont peu d'utilité
ça serait même un excellent premier pas
et si chacun des abonnés s'annonce folle
faisaient de même
ce qui nous paraissait improbable mais
si on faisait tout de même on pourra
alors réduire grandement la consommation
de 145 mille personnes sauf que 145
mille personnes c'est pas mal mais ça
reste 0,2 pour cent de la population
française et 20 millionième de la
population mondiale
autant dire que l'effet combiné de tous
les abonnés sense warhol aurait un effet
très imperceptible sur l'état de la
planète ne pas dire qu'il ne faut pas
que vous consommiez - mais ça veut dire
que le fait que nous consommions - sera
très insuffisant souvenez-vous le but
n'est pas de nous donner bonne
conscience ou d'imaginer des scénarios
hypothétiques à la si tout le monde
faisait x non notre but doit être de
réduire significativement les risques de
catastrophes environnementales
si tel est vraiment le but il nous faut
absolument faire plus que juste mieux
consommer dans ce contexte que devons
nous faire pour réduire les risques
qu'une chose qu'on pourrait faire c'est
travailler sur des solutions plus
efficaces d'un point de vue
environnemental
par exemple en diminuant la consommation
énergétique comme on l'a vu dans
l'épisode 34 la recherche en est à
d'ailleurs beaucoup à apporter à cet
effort mais on peut également travailler
sur des solutions plus efficaces dont le
domaine du transport par exemple voir
sur des technologies radicalement
différente pour produire de la
nourriture sans passer par
l'exploitation de vastes espaces qui
pourraient être remplacés par des forêts
en particulier la recherche sur la
viande propre qui consiste à concevoir
de la viande directement à partir de
cellules souches voir sur la production
de nutriments à partir de bactéries et
de sources lumineuses pourrait à terme
grandement diminuer l'impact
environnemental de nos consommations
alimentaires
bien sûr ces technologies sont encore
très loin d'être en phase
d'industrialisation massive et doivent
encore gagner le coeur du grand public
et même si elles n'ont que 1% de chance
d'arriver à leurs fins il semble que ça
vaut le coup d'investir massivement dans
cette petite probabilité sachant les
conséquences massivement bénéfique que
cela pourrait avoir
surtout si vous pouvez investir vos
compétences pour accélérer le
développement de ses technologies
malheureusement même avec tous ces
progrès technologique n'est pas dit que
cela suffise à réduire suffisamment
notre impact environnemental
dès lors on en arrive souvent à penser
aux entreprises après tout ce sont ces
entreprises qui ont le plus de pouvoir
sur les modifications de production pour
réduire les impacts environnementaux
cependant les entreprises sont surtout
dans un marché compétitif le sacrifice
individuel pour l'environnement risque
d'être pénalisé par une perte de parts
de marché ou une augmentation des prix
de vente ce qui peut conduire à des
consommateurs moins satisfaits et des
risques notamment de licenciement pour
que ces entreprises changent leur mode
de production
il faut absolument qu'il soit davantage
dans leur intérêt de se faire ce qui
doit passer par des exigences
différentes des consommateurs 1 -
peut-être de passer par des mesures
politiques et en effet il faut bien voir
qu'une législation aura sans doute bien
plus d'impact qu'une marche ponctuelles
pour le climat typiquement on pourrait
vouloir taxer beaucoup plus les
pollutions co2 que cela n'est le cas
aujourd'hui
de la même façon que les cigarettes sont
fortement taxés pour décourager leur
consommation ou pourrait également
augmenter artificiellement le prix de la
viande du carburant ou des produits
nécessitant beaucoup d'énergie et de
pollution afin de modifier les
incentives des consommateurs cependant
si telle est notre objectif il faut non
seulement convaincre les politiciens
qu'il s'agit d'une bonne action à
entreprendre mais aussi et surtout le
peuple qui élit ses politiciens
souvenez vous les politiciens ont pour
but d'être et de rester au pouvoir
ce n'est pas en les sensibilisant à
l'urgence environnementale qui se
mettront à changer de stratégie
politique pour qu'ils changent leur
stratégie politique
il faut que leurs électorats veuillent
qu'ils changent de stratégie politique
peu importe la manière dont on attaque
le problème il semble que l'impact
environnemental de l'humanité dépendra
nécessairement grandement des habitudes
et des consommateurs et des désiratas de
nos concitoyens or prendre des mesures
environnementales à grande échelle
il va falloir changer ce que ces
individus pensent veulent et font et ça
c'est vraiment pas facile pour y arriver
il faut absolument communiquer et
cherchait à influencer le plus grand
nombre il faut absolument avoir leur
attention et les sensibiliser à
l'urgence climatique et là chacun
d'entre nous peut aider en parlant
régulièrement de cette urgence et de ce
que chacun peut faire pour réduire son
impact environnemental
alors bien sûr on peut y aller avec le
bouche à oreille on peut essayer
d'influencer ses amis ses collègues et
sa famille mais attention il s'agit
d'une tâche non trivial et si vous
faites ça mal vous risquez d'avoir une
fluence contre-productive quand il
s'agit de sujets politisé nous avons
tendance à très mal recevoir la critique
est également à très mal les mettre pour
avoir une influence aussi bénéfique que
possible sur nos proches il nous est
indispensable de toujours chercher à
mieux débattre à chaque fois que vous
engager une discussion sur ce genre de
sujet il faut que quelque part dans
votre tête
une alerte achetés avec des bâtons mieux
s'allume hockey mieux débattre de ces
sujets c'est cool mais est-ce que ça
suffit imaginons que chacun d'entre nous
parvient à convaincre cinq personnes ce
qui serait déjà absolument remarquable
ça nous permettrait alors d'atteindre 1%
de la population française et 1 100
millionième de la population mondiale
donc en loin du compte pour avoir un
effet global et sachant à quel point
l'écrasante majorité de nos concitoyens
des batman le bouche à oreille ne suffit
pas il sera du coup certainement très
respectable d'institutionnaliser des
espaces de discussions qui auront plus
d'impact comme des conférences ou des
tables rondes mais tout ça prend
également beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
en fait il semble que le truc qui aura
le plus d'impact c'est de se lancer sur
les réseaux sociaux et essayer d'avoir
un message convaincant et audible qui
touchera à 50 cents peut-être même 1000
personnes là l'impact serait beaucoup
plus important est l'un des réseaux
sociaux d'aujourd'hui qui semble avoir
le plus d'impact
et bien c'est youtube en particulier où
il est possible d'avoir des arguments
l'on posé et convaincant qu'ils seront
écoutés par un millier des dizaines de
milliers voire parfois des centaines de
milliers de personnes
et d'ailleurs ces derniers temps de
nombreux youtuber se sont réunis sous lé
projet il est encore temps et on est
prêt pour participer à cette énorme de
travail de sensibilisation qu'il faut
faire pour avoir un impact
environnemental non négligeable même si
bien des choses dans ce mouvement sont
sans doute critiquable comme notamment
la faible mise en valeur à mon goût de
la rigueur scientifique et de
scientifiques experts des questions
environnementales
il vous renvoie d'ailleurs faire cette
vidéo du réveil orchidées terry bien
cette déficience
on peut espérer que l'action de faire
ces vidéos sur youtube aura un impact
non négligeable et globalement bénéfique
sur les comportements des consommateurs
et les convictions des citoyens qui
ensuite aura un impact non négligeable
et globalement bénéfique sur la
diminution des risques environnementaux
cependant même si cette campagne marché
du tonnerre
et même si elle a été suivie par des
millions de français et même si elle
parvenait à diffuser dans des millions
de foyers français pour
ainsi affecter la majorité de la
population française il reste que tout
cet effort monumental n'aura atteint au
mieux qu'un public
globalement francophone alors ça serait
déjà absolument génial et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que de ne rien
faire
mais si l'on considère que nos impacts
environnementaux pose vraiment des
risques de catastrophe majeure à
l'échelle planétaire
il me semble que ça reste néanmoins très
insuffisant notamment parce que vu les
intérêts économiques en jeu il faut
s'attendre à ce que de nombreux acteurs
chercheront à décridibiliser la campagne
en semant le doute et la discorde comme
c'est déjà le cas avec l'origine
anthropique du changement climatique
sans compter ceux qui moquent rond l'une
des inévitables bêtises que l'inde et
youtube heure du mouvement aura dit ce
qui exagère auront cette bêtise et ce
qui l'a tourneront en dérision
si vraiment on se place dans l'hypothèse
d'une véritable urgence environnementale
j'ai bien peur que l'action de quelques
youtuber aussi géniaux soit ils ne
suffisent pas pour sauver
l'environnement et éviter des risques de
catastrophe majeure
il semble qu'il nous faille faire plus
encore il nous faut entreprendre une
action à l'impact plus énorme encore
vous voyez où je veux en venir
on l'a vu dans l'épisode 29 aujourd'hui
il semble y avoir une entité sur terre
dont la force de frappe et
formidablement plus grande que celle de
n'importe quel humain je pense à
l'algorithme de recommandations de
youtube aujourd'hui en suggérant telle
ou telle vidéo non pas à une mais à un
milliard de personnes
l'algorithme de youtube est capable de
ne deviez une fraction importante de la
population vers telle ou telle idée et
l' influence de cet algorithme de
recommandations est énorme
en effet il y a plus de vues sur youtube
que de recherche sur google mais surtout
plus de la moitié des vues sur youtube
font suite à une recommandation de
l'algorithme de youtube autrement dit de
nos jours
nous n'allons plus chercher
l'information l'information nous est
servi sur un plateau et le serveur en
charge du menu que l'on va consommer
n'est autre que lire youtube une
modification un film de satire pourrait
grandement changé le contenu
informationnel que des milliards
d'individus consonnes et ça ça pourrait
grandement changé ce que ces individus
pensent
veulent et ce qu'ils font la prochaine
vidéo qu'ils verront sera t-elle une
haine plus 1e vidéo conspirationnistes
qui perçoit le viaur de croire x ou y
pour de très mauvaises raisons et
l'incitent à s'indigner à polluer les
débats sans fondement et sans action
bénéfique à proposer ou s'agira-t-il
d'une vidéo qui les amènera à réfléchir
1 pourquoi ils pensent ce qu'ils pensent
pourquoi ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent
et pourquoi ils font ce qu'ils font
s'agira-t-il d'une vidéo qui les
invitera à questionner ce qu'ils
croyaient croire à donner plus
d'importance à ce qu'ils voudraient
vouloir et à mieux anticiper les impacts
bénéfiques et néfastes de ce qu'ils font
s'agira-t-il d'une vidéo qui
accompagnera durablement leurs pensées
et les amènera à mieux mesurer
l'importance de notre impact
environnemental
aujourd'hui il ya de youtube a le
pouvoir de rendre les consommateurs plus
attentifs à l'impact environnemental de
leurs consommations et les citoyens -
sur des convictions injustifiée qu'ils
ont ne serait-il pas immoral pour satire
de ne pas user ce pouvoir pour le bien
de l'humanité
aujourd'hui il me semble que la plupart
des gens effrayés par les risques
environnementaux persistaient néanmoins
à exiger une certaine forme de
neutralité des systèmes de
recommandations comme l'ia de youtube
mais cette neutralité est une notion
extrêmement problématique être neutres
vis-à-vis du réchauffement climatique
cela correspond il à montrer aux
utilisateurs autant de vidéos pro
changement climatique que anti
changement climatique ou est-ce que
notre signifierait que pour chaque
utilisateur
la proportion de vidéo anti vaccins
recommandés soit égal à la proportion
d'anti vagues dans la population
et si on en vient à désigner des experts
n'est ce pas violer la neutralité
sachant de plus que chacun d'entre nous
préfèrent des suggestions personnalisées
me semble en fait que cette neutralité
est à la fois utopique mais aussi et
surtout indésirables de façon égoïste je
veux de l'information fiable de
l'information de qualité ou pas de
l'information neutre et en dictateur
autoritaire bienveillant je pense même
qu'ils seraient désirable qu'il en soit
de même pour tout le monde surtout dans
l'optique de protéger au mieux
l'environnement
et oui je sais que ma position est très
minoritaire et paraître est scandaleuse
pour être franc on mois du présent ce
serait bien anglais avec le mois d'il ya
un an
il soulève bien sûr plein d'autres
questions comme qui modifiera
l'algorithme avec quelle incentives
quelle mesure de robustesse et surtout
quels objectifs
mais oublions ces questions pour
aujourd'hui voilà ce à quoi je vous
invite à réfléchir
vu le pouvoir de l'ia de youtube mais
aussi celle de facebook ou twitter ne
serait-il pas temps de cesser d'y voir
de simples outils de relais
d'information
ne serait-il pas temps d'y voir un
potentiel allié formidable pour adresser
les problèmes les plus urgents de nos
sociétés modernes comme la protection de
l'environnement au 21ème siècle
l'humanité va devoir relever des défis
monumentaux me semble temps de mettre
toutes les chances de notre côté pour y
arriver la fin
parler de profondeur logique de bennett
et notamment je vous avais dit que l'une
des approches importante de fondement
important de cette approche consistait à
avoir une représentation numérique du
monde c'est à dire avec une suite
digital 2 0 et 2 1 qui peuvent
correspondre typiquement ou fichiers
jpeg mp3 ou ce que vous voulez qu'ils
permettent de représenter le monde et
san goku fait la remarque que tout ceci
ne sont que des données collectées du
monde et que peut a priori le monde
pourrait être indescriptible ainsi
typiquement le monde qu elle soit
quelque chose assez continue on a
l'impression d'un intuition comme ça que
l'espace et au temps typiquement sont
des choses très continue alors en fait
il ya pas mal de raisons de voir
néanmoins se ramener à une expression
digitale du monde à une replantation de
très près numérique du monde
la première c'est que les données qui
sont collectés notamment à cause des
erreurs de mesure en analogique ou à
cause du fait simplement qu'on n'est pas
capable d'échantillonner les signaux que
l'on mesure avec une trop grande pour et
précision à la fois dans l'espace et
dans le temps tout cela peut-être
d'ailleurs relié aux inégalités
d'eisenberg tout ceci fait que
finalement si on cherche à avoir une
description plus fine du monde que ce
qu'on est capable de mesurer ça
correspondra à des artefacts de mesure
et que du coup si on essaie d'enlever ce
bruit qui sera dans nos mesures ne se
ramène finalement à des données qui sont
déjà numérisées finalement dû certains
venir les données auxquelles on peut
faire confiance sont des données qui
sont fines en trés trés digital
donc ça ça correspond vraiment autonomie
qui stationnent et du coup sachant que
les données qu'on a collecté du monde
sont des données digitales ce que l'on
peut inférer d'une à partir de ça et -
finalement c'est ce qu'on peut inférer à
partir d'une suite finie 2-0 et 2-1 et
du coup il sachant que tout ce que l'on
a c'est ça mais il assez raisonnable de
se dire que tout ce que l'on peut
inférer sur le monde correspond
finalement une description en tout cas
avec un certain nombre fini de symboles
de 0 et de 1 et que du coup il ya un
sens à essayer de chercher à parler de
notre univers avec quelque chose de très
numérique de traits de très fines y aura
bien sûr tout ça ça peut paraître assez
satisfaisant ça peut donner l'impression
que c'est uniquement notre
représentation du monde
qui est du coup digital alors que
peut-être que le monde tel qu'il est
vraiment lui n'est pas digitale et du
coup il ya d'autres chercheurs
d'informatique qui sont posées c'est un
peu cette question notamment gandhi qui
s'est demandé quelle sont des conditions
sur l'univers qui pourrait faire que du
coup l'univers correspond vraiment à une
description qui serait exact mais à
l'aide d'un langage informatique de
quelque chose de très délicate en
particulier même si on suppose l'espace
et le temps continue
si on suppose quelques propriétés
notamment la finitude de vitesses de
transmission des signaux et le fait que
l'on ne puisse pas mettre trop d'énergie
on est en droit de l'espace-temps
correspondre à un trou noir typiquement
relativité générale
sachant que l'on a cédé conditions alors
tout ce qui se passe dans l'univers
toutes les descriptions de tout
l'univers est en fait isomorphe à une
description qui serait purement digital
qui correspondrait totalement un
automate cellulaire et du coup d'après
l'auteur ne grandit on peut se ramener
finalement à une description très
digital d'autres univers et enfin il y a
aussi des approches de la physique qui
vont directement dans quelque chose de
très discret et autant dans des
descriptions de l'espace et du temps qui
sont discrètes victor loewy lui fait la
remarque que si ça se trouve les
millions de premiers chiffres du nombre
de grammes correspondent à une suite qui
est finalement très facile à décrire
avec un algorithme très différent de
celui que j'ai décrit de la description
que j'ai donné et on cela du coup le
japon au concept de profondeur de
logique de bennett pourrait être très
insatisfaisant et en effet c'est
parfaitement le cas le million de
premiers chiffres du nombre de grammes
est a priori quelque chose qui est dont
il est très difficile de savoir quoi que
ce soit en particulier il est très
difficile a priori de déterminer la
vraie profondeur logique et 2b net du 1
million premiers chiffres du nombre de
grammes et même en fait de façon très
générale la profondeur logique de
bennett est quelque chose qui est très
inquiet q la bhl c'est à dire qu'il
n'existe pas d'algorithmes et qui
permettent de calculer la profondeur
logique de bennett d'une suite donné
même si elle était connue est donné
devant nous en fait c'est
mathématiquement impossible d'avoir un
algorithme qui va étendre et n'importe
quelle suite nous donner la profondeur
logique de bennett de cette suite et ça
a à voir avec les problèmes de la rai
dont patience parle dans cette vidéo
bon ça c'est pas très différent de la
complexité de ce logo nov qui est
également une quantité incalculable
cependant pour la complexité de
seulement 9 on peut trouver des bornes
supérieur sur
la complexité sous le nom d' une suite
puisque si on arrive à identifier un
algorithme capable de générer la suite
en question alors cet algorithme serbe
de borne supérieure est le plus court
des algorithmes pour générer cette suite
est du coup ce sera forcément plus
petits malheureusement pour la
profondeur logique de bennett
on sait que c'est très incalculables
dans le sens qu'on ne sait même pas
possible de trouver une borne supérieure
et une borne inférieure
bref la profondeur logique de bennett
c'est quelque chose de très un calcul ah
bon ça c'est très insatisfaisant et
c'est très compliqué de la manipuler en
pratique et c'est également très
d'institutions pour une autre raison qui
est le fait que la profondeur logique de
bennett et d'une quantité très peu
robuste c'est à dire que si vous changez
légèrement une suite à grande profondeur
de logique il est possible que sa
profondeur logique de bennett change
complètement du tout au tout et du coup
c'est pas une mesure très mauvais et ça
c'est très satisfaisant mais c'est même
encore pire que ça puisque la profondeur
logique de bennett dépend fortement de
la machine de turing que l'on considère
pour décrire les différents algorithmes
la profondeur logique de bennett pose
beaucoup de problèmes et c'est lié au
fait ce que pour définir rigoureusement
bayat a considéré le temps de calcul du
plus court algorithme qui génère la
suite en question est ce plus court
algues au rythme peut changer peut
devenir complètement différent si on
change légèrement la suite et du coup le
temps de calcul du nouvel algorithme
peut complètement changer
en fait ce qui serait un peu plus
robuste mais qui est beaucoup également
beaucoup plus difficile à décrire et à
étudier
c'est globalement étant donné une suite
donnée d'étudier quelle l ensemble des
algorithmes et qui génère cette suite
quels sont leurs longueurs en termes de
code algorithmique et en termes de temps
de calcul et on pourrait ensuite étudié
les algorithmes selon ces deux axes
hélas cette fois ci on change légèrement
la suite ou si on change légèrement la
machine de turing alors l'ensemble des
points dans ce graphe bougera mais il
bougera pas trop du coup droit une
grande frustration beaucoup plus robuste
finalement c'est ce genre de
représentation qui est plus pertinent
mais également plus compliqué à décrire
et à manipuler moins élégant
mathématiquement du coup plutôt que de
parler de ce graphe tous ceux qui à dire
à ce sujet c'est un raccourci à ces
pratiques que de parler directement de
profondeur logique de bennett même si
ses atouts et défauts que je viens de
j'espère qu'ils avaient aimé cette vidéo
et qu'elle n'aura pas trop éveiller le
lit gagnent en vous et j'espère surtout
que vous faire réfléchir à voix c'est
finalement s'il ya vraiment urgence
jusqu'où on est prêt à aller et
finalement des principes d'une politique
comme la neutralité
s'ils ont déjà discutable d'un point de
vue définition augmentant vraiment par
ça mais qui sont qui me semble également
discutable parce qu'il me semble
simplement bien moins importants que
d'autres problèmes de société qui me
semble beaucoup plus importants tonnes
par exemple les risques environnementaux
ceci dit l'une des très grosses
difficultés de nos jay l'algorithme de
youtube sait déjà qui convainc pas y
arriver
ce qu'il faut passer par youtube a su
progresser par le gouvernement ou par
des dirigeants importants
tout ça ce sont des questions qui me
semble absolument crucial et c'est pas
du tout mon expertise mais je pense que
ça serait intéressant de bien analyser
les incentives des uns et les autres
pour savoir quelles sont les personnes
qui elles sont les plus influençables et
les plus influents ce pour pouvoir
modifier il ya de youtube aussi on pense
que tel est l'objectif
l autre question très importante ces
quatre sont les solutions algorithmique
pour que l'algorithme de youtube
devienne un algorithme qui note que les
personnes dans la bonne direction et
notamment comment déterminer
algorithmique mans quelles sont les
vidéos moralement bonne à partager et ça
c'est un défi technique absolument
majeur et ça tombe bien ce sera le sujet
de la prochaine vidéo
si vous avez aimé cet épisode pensait le
lac et le prouvant qu'elle partage et
pensez à vous abonner panthers épisode
merci aux ti peur pour leurs dons et
j'espère qu'il serait là la prochaine
fois en fait cette vidéo est un
plaidoyer pour des mouvements
environnementaux scientifiques de plus
en plus de français s'intéressent aux
problèmes environnementaux parce qu'ils
deviennent extrêmement important et
c'est une excellente nouvelle c'est
aussi pour ça que je pense qu'il est
plus que temps de faire sortir
l'écologie politique et associatif de
certains dogmes dans lesquelles elle
s'est enfoncée depuis plusieurs
décennies
à mon avis une victoire d'une forme
d'écologie politique qui se moque des
faits et non seulement improbable mais
n'apporterait en plus rien de bon on
gaspille ray du temps et de l'énergie
dans les actions pas forcément efficace
d'ailleurs les mouvements
environnementaux existants peuvent très
bien de se corriger tout ce qu'il ya sur
le site
il est encore temps n'est pas mauvais
c'est juste que ça ne devrait pas être
aux visiteurs qui n'a pas toujours les
connaissances nécessaires de séparer le
bon grain de l'ivraie
ça devrait être fait en amont et non à l
abri